Araukanien.
Eine der schönsten Landschaften
Chiles.
Die Gegend
wird chilenische Schweiz genannt -
wegen der Berge,
aber auch, weil Ende des 19. Jh.
22'000 Schweizer
hierher ausgewandert sind.
Doch die Idylle täuscht.
Die Nachfahren der Schweizer Siedler
werden bedroht.
Mein Rechtsanwalt hat mir gesagt:
"Wenn du dich weiter wehrst,
wirst du getötet."
Die Mapuche-Indianer,
die indigene Bevölkerung,
fordern von ihnen das Land zurück.
Mit der Rückgewinnung des Landes
können wir unsere wirtschaftliche
Situation verbessern.
Wir können die Natur schützen
und unsere traditionelle Lebensweise
wiederfinden.
Wir wollen
ein würdiges Leben führen.
Die Siedler
sollen in ihre Länder zurück.
Sie sind nicht von hier, wir schon.
Die Siedler
haben das Land urbar gemacht.
Jetzt, nach fünf Generationen,
sollen sie alles aufgeben?
Aufgeben ist nicht unser Ziel.
Darum sind wir hier.
Viele unserer Freunde sagen immer:
"Was macht ihr da?"
Aber das ist unser Land.
* Leise Klänge *
Februar - Erntezeit in Chile.
Ewald Luchsinger
und sein Bruder Harald
bewirtschaften die Santa Rosa.
60 ha gross.
Die Schweizer
sind stolz auf ihren Besitz,
stolz auf das,
was ihre Vorväter aufgebaut haben.
Doch das Land, auf dem sie leben,
wollen ihnen die Nachbarn wegnehmen.
Es sind Mapuche-Indianer,
Ureinwohner der Region.
Einige von ihnen
arbeiten als Erntehelfer
auf den Feldern der Luchsingers -
Akkordarbeit zu Minimallöhnen.
Andere Mapuche behaupten,
das Land gehöre ihnen,
und nicht den Schweizern.
Das Verhältnis zu den Nachbarn
war immer gut.
Wir hatten lange
eine gute Beziehung zu ihnen.
Unsere Familie
lebt seit ca. 1908 in dieser Region.
Das sind über 100 Jahre.
Und wir hatten immer
ein gutes Verhältnis.
So kenne ich es
seit meiner Kindheit. Nicht anders.
Darum ist es für uns sehr ...
schwer zu verstehen,
wie es dazu kommen konnte.
Die Arbeit auf der Farm
ist gefährlich geworden.
Seit 2009 wurde die Santa Rosa
immer wieder angegriffen.
Seien es Brände,
sei es die Zerstörung von Maschinen,
sei es ... Was weiss ich.
Bis hin
zu Eisenstücken in den Feldern,
damit die Maschinen kaputtgehen.
Der wirtschaftliche Schaden
ist enorm -
die Familie
ist in ihrer Existenz bedroht.
Die Luchsingers hatten 220 Milchkühe.
Heute stehen die Stallungen leer.
Sie mussten all ihre Kühe verkaufen.
2015 ist bei einem Anschlag
eine Molkerei völlig abgebrannt.
Wenn man einen Betrieb hat und das
zerstört wird, hat man nichts mehr.
Da hat man
nur Schulden bei den Banken
und muss wieder neu anfangen
und sagen: "Was mache ich jetzt?"
Meine Eltern leben noch
und mein Vater sagte immer:
"Ich verkaufe nicht."
Und so soll es auch bleiben.
Und doch:
Die Luchsingers sind auf dem Rückzug.
Die Eltern der Brüder haben den Hof
verlassen - aus Angst vor Anschlägen.
Weder Ewald noch Harald trauen sich,
einzuziehen.
Mein Bruder und ich
wohnen in der Stadt.
Unsere Frauen
wollen nicht hier leben.
Das ist natürlich etwas grausam,
aber es ist die Realität.
Die Polizei bewacht das Wohnhaus rund
um die Uhr, sieben Tage die Woche.
Hola, como estan? Que tal.
- Muy bien.
Seit fünf Jahren steht es leer.
Spuren des letzten Angriffs.
In diese Richtung wurde geschossen.
Die Angreifer
hatten Benzinkanister dabei.
Sie wollten das Haus abbrennen.
Drinnen sieht es noch aus
wie an dem Tag,
als die Eltern das Haus verliessen.
Hier sind wir im Wohnzimmer mit
Kamin. Da ist ein Familienwappen.
Das haben wir
aus Holz machen lassen.
Wir haben die Skizze natürlich
aus der Schweiz mitgebracht.
Und das wurde hier von einem ...
... Artesano gemacht.
Die Familie stammt aus Engi
im Kanton Glarus.
Es waren hauptsächlich Landwirte.
Sie sind im Jahr 1883
nach Quechereguas, Chile, gekommen.
Der Bus
aus der Regionalhauptstadt Temuco.
Einmal pro Woche kauft
Familie Tralcal in der Stadt ein.
Dinge, die sie zu Hause auf der Farm
nicht produzieren können.
Die Tralcals
gehören zu den Mapuche-Familien,
die um die Rückgabe von Land kämpfen.
Juan, der älteste Sohn, trägt
die Verantwortung für die Familie.
Er ist 26 und studiert Geologie.
Mit den Luchsingers
streiten die Tralcals bald 20 Jahre.
Erst ging es um Wasserrechte,
dann ums Land.
Viel Zeit für die Arbeit auf dem Hof
bleibt Juan wegen des Studiums nicht.
Der Familie mangelt es an allem.
Die 10 ha Land werfen zu wenig ab,
um davon leben zu können.
Mit einfachen Handwerksarbeiten
verdienen sie sich etwas dazu.
Er wird hart ausgetragen.
Das Land gehört unseren Vorfahren.
Es steht eigentlich uns zu.
Ich bin aber dagegen,
dass man Familien bedroht
und ihnen Gewalt antut.
Viele Mapuche
sind nicht damit einverstanden.
Doch die Zerstörung von Maschinen,
die unser Land kaputt machen -
diese Form von Gewalt
ist eine Reaktion
auf die Gewalt des Staates.
Die Frauen verarbeiten die Wolle
der eigenen Schafe.
Irma und Maria
teilen sich die Aufgabe.
Zwei Frauen, ein Haushalt -
bei den Mapuche
ist es nicht ungewöhnlich,
dass ein Mann mit zwei Frauen lebt.
Maria will den Poncho
für umgerechnet 375 Fr. verkaufen.
Ein lächerlicher Preis bei einem
Arbeitsaufwand von mehreren Wochen.
So wird die Familie
nie der Armut entkommen.
Wir Mapuche sind immer noch arm.
Anders als die Siedler haben wir
kein Kapital für Investitionen.
Sie sind mit nichts hierhergekommen.
Aber die Regierung
hat sie unterstützt.
Was sie aufgebaut haben, haben sie
nicht aus eigener Kraft geschafft.
Heute besitzen sie viele Maschinen
und haben Arbeitskräfte.
Araukanien ist die Kornkammer Chiles.
Das haben die Siedler geschafft.
Im 19. Jh. hat der chilenische Staat
sie angeworben:
Deutsche, Franzosen, Italiener
und 22'000 Schweizer.
Sie haben das noch wilde Land
für den jungen chilenischen Staat
urbar gemacht.
* Unverständliche Gespräche, Lachen *
Die Luchsingers
gehörten zu den ersten Siedlern.
Heute besitzen sie mehrere Farmen.
Sie sind durch die Landwirtschaft
zu Wohlstand gekommen.
* Stimmengewirr *
Wenn sie gemeinsam feiern,
wird deutlich:
Grüezi!
- Grüezi!
Hola, Mica! Hola, Mica.
Hola, mi amor.
Die Jüngsten
sprechen meist nur noch Spanisch,
die Älteren
mehr oder weniger gut Deutsch.
Der Schweizer Dialekt ist verloren,
bestenfalls bleiben ein paar Brocken.
Doch der Schweiz
fühlen sie sich noch sehr verbunden.
Zum Fest haben sie Fotos mitgebracht,
Dokumente
von der Ansiedlung in der neuen Welt.
Das erste Haus - die Familie
hat es noch selbst gebaut.
Die Aconcagua, das Schiff, auf dem
die Siedler einen Monat reisten.
Der Vertrag mit dem chilenischen
Staat: 40 ha Land für jeden Siedler.
Und Urvater Sebastian -
wenige Jahre zuvor
hatte er mit seiner Familie
die Schweiz aus Armut verlassen.
Aus Engi im Kanton Glarus
kam die Familie.
In Chile
gelangte sie rasch zu Wohlstand.
Die Luchsingers
kauften neues Land hinzu
und zogen in zweiter Generation
in die Gegend von Temuco.
(Mann) Das ist das erste Stück.
Die Aconcagua, das Schiff, auf dem
die Siedler einen Monat reisten.
Das hat mein Gross... mein Gross-
vater gekauft, also Adam Luchsinger,
und dann
haben die Brüder Luchsinger-Ruf
die anderen Teile gekauft,
bis es 1'300 ha waren.
So viel haben sie gekauft,
und die Frauen haben gemeckert,
dass immer mehr Ländereien
gekauft wurden und nichts fürs Haus.
Die Luchsingers,
und wie sie viele andere Siedler,
werden reich und reicher,
die Mapuche dagegen verarmen.
Heute
fordern sie das geraubte Land zurück.
Land, das die Siedler
seit 140 Jahren bewirtschaften.
Sind Sie stolz auf Ihre Geschichte?
- Ja, claro.
Uns ist nichts geschenkt worden,
nichts.
Der Einzige, der verantwortlich
dafür ist, was jetzt passiert,
ist unser Staat.
Er hat kolonisiert.
Er hat die Mapuche
auf kleine Flächen verdrängt
und den Rest des Landes versteigert.
Jetzt stehen die Luchsingers
im Zentrum des Konflikts.
Besonders hart traf es Jorge Andres:
2013 wurden seine Eltern
Opfer eines Anschlags,
genau in dem Haus,
in dem sie heute feiern.
Die Polizei zeichnete den Notruf auf.
(Spanisch)
Ich bin wenig später
beim Haus angekommen.
Auf dem Weg habe ich gesehen,
dass das Haus in Flammen steht
und dass der Brand
in der Küche ausgebrochen ist.
Ich glaube, dass ich die Angreifer
ganz knapp verpasst habe.
Ich habe meine Mama gesucht,
die mich vor wenigen Minuten
angerufen hatte.
Nachdem wir sie
die ganze Nacht gesucht hatten,
haben wir am Morgen erfahren, dass
zwei Körper im Haus gefunden wurden.
Es war bereits völlig abgebrannt.
Entgegen unserer Hoffnung
bestätigte sich,
dass es
die Überreste meiner Eltern waren.
Das Elternhaus haben Jorge Andres
und seine Brüder wieder aufgebaut.
Niemand wohnt mehr darin.
Es dient der Familie
als Ort der Zusammenkunft
und ist eine Botschaft an die Täter.
Ihr könnt kommen, ihr könnt alles
niederbrennen, ihr könnt uns töten,
aber euer Ziel
werdet ihr nicht erreichen.
Für den Anschlag
auf das Ehepaar Luchsinger
werden drei Mapuche
verantwortlich gemacht.
Einer der Verurteilten ist ihr Vater,
Jose Tralcal.
In einem ersten Verfahren
wurde er freigesprochen.
Doch die Regierung
legte Berufung ein,
und dann wurde er
zu 18 Jahren Gefängnis verurteilt.
Jose Tralcal
entzog sich der Haft durch Flucht.
Für die Brüder ist klar: Ihr Vater
ist Opfer einer grossen Intrige.
Es sind neun Personen
angeklagt worden.
Alles Personen,
die andere führen können
und die über das Wissen
und die Fähigkeit verfügen,
Landansprüche
gegen den Staat durchzusetzen.
Es ging um das Land der Siedler,
ganz besonders
im Fall der Luchsingers.
Nur deswegen
wollte man sie wegsperren.
Man hat die Leute für den Mord an
dem Ehepaar verantwortlich gemacht,
die für die Rechte der Mapuche
kämpfen.
Tatsache ist:
Ihr Vater Jose Tralcal war einer
der führenden Köpfe im Landstreit.
Er hatte sich mit dem alten Jorge
Luchsinger jahrzehntelang gestritten.
* Krähen *
Tatsache ist auch:
Im ersten Verfahren
wurden die
von der Polizei vorgelegten Beweise
wegen des Verdachts auf Manipulation
abgewiesen.
Für die Kinder ist daher klar:
Der Prozess ist eine Verschwörung
des Staates gegen ihren Vater.
* Rhythmische Flötenklänge, Gesang *
Jose Tralcal -
die Mapuche sehen in ihm
einen Märtyrer
im Kampf für die Rechte ihres Volkes.
Sein Verteidiger kommt -
wie immer zu Fuss.
Mapuche zu verteidigen,
ist kein einträgliches Geschäft.
Como va todo?
- Bien, bien.
Hola.
- Hola, como esta?
Pablo Ortega kann nach dem Urteil
des Obersten Gerichtshofs in Chile
nicht mehr viel für die Tralcals tun.
Deswegen will er
an den Interamerikanischen
Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte.
Da sieht er weit bessere Chancen.
Se llama
"Pacto de Derechos Humanos ...
Convencion Americana
de Derechos Humanos".
Chile habe im Prozess
ein Gesetz aus der Zeit
der Pinochet-Diktatur angewandt,
das sog. Anti-Terror-Gesetz.
Das schränke die Rechte
der Verteidigung stark ein
und verstosse klar
gegen international geltende Normen.
Das Gesetz gegen den Terrorismus
hat Pinochet benutzt,
um die Demonstranten festzunehmen,
die sich für soziale Rechte
stark gemacht haben.
Und ebendieses Gesetz wird jetzt im
Konflikt mit den Mapuche angewandt.
Mit dem gleichen Massstab,
mit dem Gesetz von Pinochet,
wird heute gegen die Gemeinde
der Mapuche vorgegangen.
* Pablo spricht im Hintergrund. *
Pablo geht noch einen Schritt weiter.
Chile
habe ein politisches Urteil gefällt,
das unter dem Druck der Siedler
zustande gekommen sei.
Mmh, que bueno.
Heute sind die Nachfahren
der Grossgrundbesitzer
auf allen Ebenen der Gesellschaft
vertreten:
in den Gerichten,
der Polizei und der Administration.
Sie bestimmen
über die Sicht der Dinge.
Die Mapuche haben keine Chance,
sich dagegen durchzusetzen.
Der Graben könnte nicht tiefer sein.
Pablo Ortega sieht sich
im Kampf gegen eine Justiz,
die das Recht der Herrschenden
vertritt.
* Schwere, pulsierende Klänge *
Mira! Vamos para la casa?
- Para que?
Lissette Melillan
ist in einer ähnlichen Situation.
Ihr Mann Luis Tralcal wurde
ebenfalls zu 18 Monaten verurteilt
und ist flüchtig.
Ahora!
- Ya, vamos.
Auch ihre Familie
kämpfte gegen Jorge Luchsinger.
Neun Jahre
haben sie mit ihm um Land gerungen.
Heute lebt Lissette
auf einem Teil des Landstücks,
das zuvor Jorge gehörte.
Doch Lissette will mehr.
Es gibt noch viele Mapuche-Familien,
die kein Land haben.
Der Kampf unseres Volkes
ist noch nicht vorbei.
Und genau deswegen
sind die Tralcals verurteilt worden.
Es ist rein politisch.
Besonders bei Luis,
denn er hat begonnen,
das Landgut eines anderen
Luchsingers zurückzuerobern.
Es geht um uns als Gemeinschaft.
Wir haben das Anrecht
auf ein würdiges Leben.
Die Siedler
sollen in ihre Länder zurückgehen.
Sie sind nicht von hier,
wir aber sind von hier.
Lissette sucht nicht einfach
den persönlichen Gewinn.
Vielmehr geht es ihr darum,
ein historisches Unrecht
rückgängig zu machen.
Sie ist stolz
auf ihre Identität als Mapuche.
Sie kleidet sich traditionell
und röstet Weizen nach altem Brauch.
Mama?
- Que?
Yo tengo esto ahora, mira.
- Si, chinita.
Lissette
nimmt auch eigenes Leid in Kauf,
etwa, dass die Kinder
ohne Vater aufwachsen.
Gewalt ist für sie
ein legitimes Mittel.
Wenn man
die Siedler vertreiben will,
muss man sie
an ihrem wunden Punkt treffen.
Das ist die Wirtschaftskraft.
Deswegen hat man angefangen,
die Ernte abzubrennen
und ihre Rinder zu töten.
Doch man muss wissen, dass
die Gewalt zuerst vom Staat ausging
gegen das Volk der Mapuche.
Der Staat brachte die Siedler her.
Der Staat fing mit der Pacificacion
von Araukanien den Krieg an
und zwang uns,
in kleinen Gebieten zu leben.
Pacificacion, Befriedung,
nennt es die offizielle
Geschichtsschreibung beschönigend.
Für die Mapuche bedeutete es
Besetzung und Unterwerfung.
Der chilenische Staat nahm den
Halbnomaden 90 % ihres Territoriums
und pferchte sie in Reservate.
Mit dem Land
ging ihre Lebensweise verloren.
Mit den neuen Gegebenheiten
kamen die Mapuche nicht zurecht.
Das Land, das ihnen der Staat gab,
war schlecht.
Und anders als die Siedler
bekamen sie keine Unterstützung.
Das einst wohlhabende Volk
der Mapuche verarmte zusehends.
Was macht das Volk der Mapuche
in dieser Situation?
Die Mapuche üben Selbstverteidigung.
Zur Strategie der Selbstverteidigung
gehört politische Gewalt,
wie wir es nennen.
Im Zentrum der politischen Gewalt
steht der Boykott.
Unter Boykott
verstehen wir Aktionen,
die sich gegen die wirtschaftliche
Macht der Siedler richten,
gegen Forstwirtschaft und Bergbau.
Gegen alle Unternehmungen,
die unsere Ressourcen ausbeuten.
Die Mapuche
haben sich in der Geschichte
erfolgreich gegen die Inka und die
spanischen Konquistadoren gewehrt.
Lissette
sieht sich in dieser Tradition.
* Fröhliche Rufe *
* Sanfte Marimbaklänge *
Ein paar Kilometer entfernt
hat Jorge Andres seine Farm.
Er hat junge Rebstöcke angepflanzt.
Deswegen lässt er nach Wasser bohren.
Er braucht es
fürs Haus und die Reben.
No te queda mucha agua.
- Ya mande a ...
Yo deje ...
- Pero el agua no ...
Auch seine Farm wird rund um die Uhr
von der Polizei bewacht.
Jorge lebt seit Jahrzehnten
mit der Bedrohung durch die Mapuche
und er kennt ihre Forderung
nach mehr Land.
Die Armut der Mapuche
hier auf dem Land ist unübersehbar.
Man muss sich
in ihre Position hineinversetzen.
Aber ich kann den Weg der Gewalt
nicht akzeptieren,
wenn sie Höfe oder die Ernte
abbrennen und Menschen ermorden.
So vergelten sie
Unrecht mit Unrecht.
Einen wichtigen Grund für die Gewalt
sieht Jorge Andres im Ley Indigena.
Das Gesetz regelt die Rückgabe
von Land an die Mapuche.
Eine Wiedergutmachung des Staates
für die historische Schuld.
Aber das Gesetz
ist schlecht durchdacht.
Das Gesetz fördert Gewalt:
Es unterstützt Landkäufe ausgerech-
net dann, wenn ein Konflikt besteht.
Deswegen wurden in den letzten
Jahren bewusst Konflikte geschürt.
So lässt sich der Prozess
der Landrückgabe beschleunigen.
Auf der anderen Seite
werden diejenigen benachteiligt,
die rechtmässig vorgehen.
Feuer. Ein Feld ist abgebrannt.
Im Februar, wenn der Sommer
auf der Südhalbkugel zu Ende geht,
ist die Natur völlig ausgetrocknet.
Feuer brechen in dieser Jahreszeit
regelmässig aus.
Eine Unachtsamkeit genügt,
Selbstentzündung ist möglich -
oder aber
Brandstiftung ist der Grund.
* Leise, beklemmende Klänge *
Auch die Weizenfelder von
Hector Urban brennen immer wieder.
In diesem Fall breitete sich
das Feuer rasend schnell aus.
Die Bauernfamilie konnte es
knapp vor den Wohnhäusern stoppen.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Ewald hat vom Anschlag erfahren
und ist gekommen,
um sich den Schaden
beim befreundeten Bauern anzusehen.
* Unverständliches Gespräch *
Die Arbeit von einem ganzen Jahr.
Unser täglich Brot.
Als ob wir es nicht brauchten.
Es war der Rest der Ernte.
Acht Anschläge hatten die Urbans
allein dieses Jahr,
insgesamt 46 ha mit Weizen
sind abgebrannt.
Kaum zu glauben,
dass die Familie da nicht aufgibt.
Wir haben keine andere Wahl.
Das oder nichts.
Wir können nirgends hin.
Wir sind an das Land gebunden.
Das ist das einzige, was wir haben.
Und um hier wegzukommen,
müssten wir es verkaufen.
Aber niemand würde es kaufen.
Als betroffene Familie,
die in diesem Konflikt steckt,
fühlen wir uns
vom chilenischen Staat betrogen.
Denn der chilenische Staat
ist ins Ausland gegangen,
in die Schweiz, nach Deutschland,
Frankreich und Italien,
um Leute zu rekrutieren,
damit sie hier arbeiten
und die Nation gross machen.
* Zügige, perlende Klänge *
Temuco, Hauptstadt der Region
und kommerzielles Zentrum.
* Stimmengewirr *
Auf dem Markt verkaufen viele Mapuche
der Umgebung ihre Produkte.
Hier kommen sie zusammen:
deutsche Siedler, Schweizer Siedler
und Mapuche.
Wenn sie sich in einem Punkt
einig sind, dann darin:
Der Staat hat seine Bürger betrogen.
Er trägt die Schuld am Konflikt.
Nie hat er sich ernsthaft bemüht,
das Zusammenleben zwischen den
Bevölkerungsgruppen zu harmonisieren.
Er hat sie gegeneinander ausgespielt
und lässt sie heute
in ihrem Kampf allein.
* Zügige, perlende Klänge *
Im Geschäftsviertel der Stadt
ist Ewald unterwegs.
Er hat sich längst ein zweites Stand-
bein als Immobilienmakler aufgebaut.
Hola, buenos dias.
Como estas, Sandra? - Muy bien.
Alguna complicacion de tiempo?
- Si.
Manana creo que vamos ...
- Pero manana ...
Estamos a 25 hoy dia, verdad?
- Si.
26 ... - Manana salen varios.
- Si, sale perfecto. Okay.
Über Jahre waren v.a. die Luchsingers
im Fokus der Anschläge.
Viele sagen,
weil die Luchsingers die Mapuche
besonders schlecht behandelt hätten.
Ewald hat eine andere Erklärung.
Wir sind natürlich
auch von der Lage her exponiert.
Man sieht, hier hat es ein
grosses Gelände, Santa Margarita.
Es ragt mitten hinein in Mapuche-
gemeinden, die ringsherum sind.
Wir haben ständig Probleme,
tagtäglich,
und das macht die Arbeit
ziemlich schwer.
So war das mal bei uns,
mit Kühen und Gras.
Und so war es danach, nicht wahr.
Das ist die Molkerei
und das ein Schuppen,
wo wir das Futtermaterial hatten.
So wurden die Viecher geschlachtet,
nur um Schaden anzurichten.
Längst sind die Luchsingers
nicht mehr die einzigen Opfer.
Die Anschläge
richten sich gegen zahlreiche
Institutionen der Gesellschaft.
Ewald führt uns zur Multigremial,
dem Verband der lokalen Wirtschaft.
Der Verband
will Frieden für die Region.
Frieden heisst für ihn: Der Staat
muss härter durchgreifen als bisher.
Der Tod und die Ermordung
des Ehepaars Luchsinger-MacKay
in seinem Haus
sind das Resultat
schrankenloser Gewalt.
Der Staat ist unfähig, bestens
bekannte Gruppierungen zu bestrafen.
Von der Polizei über die
Geheimdienste bis zu den Richtern
ist er unfähig, Urteile zu fällen,
die die Täter
ein für alle Mal festsetzen.
* Unverständliches Gespräch *
Mirtha Casas zeigt uns,
wie stark die Anschläge
im letzten Jahr zugenommen haben.
Der Streit um das Land bedrohe die
chilenische Gesellschaft als Ganzes.
Deswegen unterstützt Mirtha Casas die
Anwendung des Anti-Terror-Gesetzes,
das aus der Zeit
der Diktatur von Pinochet stammt.
Schluss damit. Wir haben
nichts mit Pinochet zu tun.
Das Gesetz
verschafft Sicherheit im 21. Jh.
Es ermöglicht
Informationsbeschaffung,
was die Angriffe radikaler,
gewalttätiger Gruppierungen
auf ihre Mitbürger verhindert.
* Dynamische Klänge *
Mit Pinochet
die Mapuche unterdrücken,
mit dem Ley Indigena
Gewalt belohnen -
der Staat hat es versäumt,
das Problem grundsätzlich anzugehen.
Hin- und hergerissen zwischen
politischen Interessengruppen
entfernt sich Chile von einer Lösung,
anstatt ihr näher zu kommen.
Ewald
bringt uns zu einer Frauengruppe.
Diese will landesweit Aufmerksamkeit
für ihre Probleme schaffen:
Anschläge auf Höfe, Gewalt gegen ihre
Kinder, Leben in permanenter Angst.
Hallo.
400 Mitglieder zählt die Gruppe.
Eine deutschstämmige Bäuerin
ist bereit, mit uns zu reden.
Ihren Namen sollen wir nicht nennen -
zu oft werde ihre Gruppe
als rechts abqualifiziert.
Ihr gehe es um die Familie.
Ich möchte, dass meine Kinder ...
in Ruhe gross werden,
dass sie nicht wegziehen müssen.
Das ist ihre Heimat hier.
Die Angriffe in der Region hat sie
in einem Kalender aufgezeichnet.
Wir, die Gruppe
Mujeres por la Araucania,
sahen, dass es
in der Presse nicht auftaucht
und die Leute in Santiago nichts
von dieser ganzen Sache wissen.
Da haben wir uns überlegt,
was wir tun können,
damit die Leute das mal sehen.
Dann hatten wir diese Idee, und nun
haben wir seit 2016 einen Kalender.
Das Resultat ist dramatisch:
Es gibt im Monat mehr Tage
mit Anschlägen als Tage ohne.
Natürlich ist das
ein Angriff auf Ihr Hab und Gut,
je nachdem sogar auf Ihr Leben.
Trotzdem die Frage: Haben Sie Ver-
ständnis dafür, dass Mapuche sagen,
sie wollen Länder zurück, die man
ihnen früher Mal genommen hat?
Ich habe es am Anfang verstanden.
Aber jetzt haben sie
so viele Ländereien und so viel ...
... Ländereien und Hilfe bekommen,
und da passiert nichts.
Das ist jetzt unproduktives Land.
Ich bin Landwirtin,
und wenn ich sehe,
dass es da jetzt nur Murra und Pica-
Pica hat und nichts angebaut wird,
verstehe ich das nicht.
* Rhythmische, dunkle Klänge *
Der Vorwurf an die Mapuche,
sie seien faul und unproduktiv,
kommt häufig vonseiten der Siedler.
Doch was für die Siedler
Faulheit ist,
ist für die Mapuche
Leben in Harmonie mit der Natur.
Es geht um die Beziehung der Mapuche
zur Erde.
Es geht um das Gleichgewicht.
Wir lassen der Erde Zeit,
sich zu erholen.
Wir fangen nicht an,
Wälder, Flüsse, Seen oder
Küstenlandschaften zu verändern.
Wir respektieren die Natur so,
wie sie ist.
Denn wir wissen, dass auch andere
Tiere sie als Lebensraum benötigen.
Die Mapuche machen sich,
anders als die Christen,
die Erde nicht untertan.
Sie sehen sie als ein Ganzes
und sich selbst als ein Teil davon.
Die Natur
ist für die Mapuche beseelt.
Es gibt einen Ort,
wo sich die Nien aufhalten.
Sie sind die Hüter der Erde.
Sie sind Geistwesen.
Auch unsere Vorfahren sind Nien.
* Folkloreklänge *
Man muss eine tiefe Beziehung
zur Erde aufbauen.
Man muss tief im Innern erkennen,
wer die Nien sind.
Ohne sie verlieren wir
die Beziehung zur Natur.
Es gibt sehr viele Nien.
Mehr als Menschen.
Wir Menschen leben kurz,
die Nien leben ewig.
Die drei wollen an einen Ort gehen,
wo sich Nien aufhalten.
Sie bitten um Erlaubnis.
* Murmeln *
Sie klagen den Nien, dass sie
fälschlicherweise beschuldigt werden
für den Tod an den Luchsingers.
* Sie sprechen Mapudungun. *
Als Geschenk
streuen sie Mehl ins Wasser.
Für die Mapuche
war immer die Natur das Paradies.
Wir wollen
keine grossen Dinge schaffen,
denn die Bauwerke der Natur
sind bedeutender
als die Bauwerke der Menschen.
Deswegen gibt es bei den Mapuche,
anders als bei den Azteken und
Mayas, keine grossartigen Bauwerke.
Mit der Kolonisation haben wir uns
von der Natur entfernt.
Wenn wir nun
unseren Lebensraum zurückgewinnen,
finden wir zurück zu den Pflanzen,
zum Glauben,
zur Sprache und Spiritualität.
* Sanfte Marimbaklänge *
Der heilige Ort:
ein natürlicher, unberührter Wald.
Hier gibt es
zahlreiche Pflanzen und Kräuter,
über deren Nutzen
Irma und Maria gut Bescheid wissen.
Wenn du krank bist,
sagt dir der Hüter des Waldes
in einem Traum,
welches Heilmittel du brauchst.
Denn du bist ein Mapuche,
ein Mensch der Erde.
Dann suchen wir das Heilmittel,
und wenn wir es finden,
weihen wir ihm ein Gebet.
Dann gehen wir nach Hause,
um die Medizin zuzubereiten.
Und schon bevor du das Heilmittel
zubereitest ... fühlst du dich gut.
* Sanfte Marimbaklänge *
Juan nimmt uns mit zu Jose Quidel.
Er ist der Lonco, der traditionelle
Führer der Mapuche-Gemeinde.
* Sie sprechen Mapudungun. *
Como esta?
- Bien, todo bien. Adelante.
Er ist aber auch
Professor für Geschichte
an der katholischen Universität
von Temuco.
Er ist überzeugt: Die Mapuche müssen
Identität und Stolz wiederfinden,
um zu ihren Rechten zu kommen.
Wir hatten keine Rechte mehr.
Kein Recht auf Bildung, kein Recht
auf medizinische Versorgung,
kein Recht auf Würde.
Das wird nicht aufhören, solange wir
uns als Mapuche nicht wiederfinden.
Den Mapuche wurde alles genommen.
Besonders hervorgetan
hätten sich dabei die Luchsingers,
als sie sich
hier in der Region niederliessen.
Die Luchsingers
hatten ein Lebensmittelgeschäft -
der alte Konrad Luchsinger.
Er sah, dass die Leute Hunger hatten
und hat ihnen Lebensmittel angebo-
ten, damit sie etwas zu essen haben.
Die Leute konnten nicht bezahlen und
haben sich immer weiter verschuldet.
Dann ist er mit Polizisten gekommen.
Er hat ihre Tiere genommen,
ihr Hab und Gut,
und schliesslich auch ihr Land.
Man muss nur fragen, mit wie vielen
Hektaren Land sie begonnen haben
und wie viel Land sie heute haben.
Auf dem Familienfest konfrontieren
wir Jorge mit der Geschichte.
Wenn Sie da hineinschauen
und sich das anschauen -
alles, was die Luchsingers vom Staat
bekommen haben, wurde bezahlt.
Sie haben kein Land von Mapuche
bekommen, immer nur gekauft?
Nichts.
Keinen Quadratmeter von den Mapuche.
Das waren alles Privatunternehmer.
Also private Bauern?
- Ja.
Ob wahr oder nicht: Die Geschichte
klebt an den Luchsingers
und macht sie
zum bevorzugten Ziel von Angriffen.
Das bekommt auch
die junge Generation zu spüren.
Ich gehe nicht gern auf die Strasse,
weil es gefährlich ist.
Jemand könnte mir was antun.
Z.B. an der Universität:
Wenn wir Studenten
über solche Themen sprechen,
kann ich nicht Stellung beziehen,
weil es zu gefährlich ist.
So wie er
habe auch ich Probleme
an meiner Schule in Temuco.
Es gibt Mitschüler,
die für Mapuche sind,
und solche, die gegen sie sind.
Einmal wurde ich bedroht.
Ich bin in die Schule gekommen
und an der Wand stand:
"Raus mit den Luchsingers -
Tod den Luchsingers".
Joyce, die Tochter von Jorge Andres,
musste jahrelang
unter Polizeischutz zur Schule gehen.
Trotzdem:
Sie möchte auf dem Land bleiben.
Ich liebe das Land.
Wenn ich Kinder habe,
will ich, dass meine Kinder
auch hier leben können.
Die anderen aber haben genug.
Seit wir fünf Jahre alt sind,
leben wir hier mit dem Konflikt.
Wir haben die Nase voll davon.
Als Kinder haben wir viele Ge-
schichten gehört. Erfüllt von Hass.
Aber wir hassen niemanden,
es bringt nichts.
Doch eine Zukunft auf dem Land
sehen wir nicht.
Sie sind gut ausgebildet
und haben wenig Interesse
an der Landwirtschaft.
Der Kampf der Eltern macht für die
nächste Generation kaum mehr Sinn.
* Fröhliche Musik aus Lautsprechern *
Anders
ist die Situation bei den Mapuche.
Sie sehen die Chance, ihr Schicksal
selbst in die Hand zu nehmen.
Am Rapa Maquehue machen sie es vor:
Kein Sponsor bestimmt über das
Festival, keine Polizei passt auf.
Auch die Familie Tralcal ist dabei.
Juan und seine Geschwister
verdienen hier Geld.
Geld für den geplanten Prozess
am Interamerikanischen Gerichtshof.
Sie wollen den Vater zurück.
Wenn jemand
zu so vielen Jahren verurteilt wird,
ist das, als ob er gestorben wäre.
Der Vater fehlt in der Familie,
er fehlt den Kindern,
er fehlt im Haus und auf dem Feld.
Das ist hart.
Und wir wissen,
dass er unschuldig ist.
* Er rappt auf Spanisch. *
Ein Staat, der sie kriminalisiert
und diskriminiert.
Sie fühlen sich ausgestossen
und wollen
eine eigene, autonome Gesellschaft.
Abseits der grossen Bühne
treffen sich in einem Zelt
politisch aktive Mapuche.
(Frau) Tengo un hijo
que es periodista.
Y su profesion
esta a servicio de la lucha.
Sie diskutieren
über das Leben in der Gemeinde,
über Politik und
neue Formen des Befreiungskampfes.
Es ist ein Parlament,
ein Ort des Gesprächs,
des Austausches, der Meinungsbildung.
Die Leute haben über ihre Erfah-
rungen im Befreiungskampf erzählt
und ihre Meinung zur
aktuellen Situation ausgetauscht.
Ich denke, der Anlass ist wichtig.
Wir sollten damit weitermachen
und mehr Leute dafür gewinnen.
Erst
müssen wir miteinander diskutieren
und dann handeln.
Das ist der richtige Weg.
* Fröhliche Partymusik *
Fest und Politik
gehen fliessend ineinander über.
Juan hat noch einen Auftritt.
Die Verurteilung von Jose und Luis
sei weit mehr als ein Schlag
gegen die Familie Tralcal.
Vielmehr sei das Urteil
ein Angriff auf das Volk der Mapuche.
(Frau) Libertad a todos!
* Rufe *
Quiero dedicar este escenario
a la familia Tralcal.
* Rufe *
Es war ein ungerechtes Urteil
im Fall Luchsinger-MacKay
gegen unsere Brüder, die Tralcals.
Sie sind auf der Flucht vor der ras-
sistischen chilenischen Regierung.
Aber wir werden den Kampf
für unsere Freiheit,
für Autonomie und Selbstbestimmung
weiterführen.
Wir kämpfen für die Unabhängigkeit
von dem Staat,
der uns so lange unterdrückt hat.
Freiheit für unser Land,
Freiheit für Luis und Jose Tralcal!
* Rufe *
Ya, ya, ya, ya, ya!
Zehn Tage nach dem Auftritt
von Juan und seinen Geschwistern
werden Jose Tralcal und Luis Tralcal
von der Polizei gefasst.
* Dunkle Klänge *
Die Politik des chilenischen Staats
gegenüber den Mapuche
ist bis heute widersprüchlich.
Weder die Linke noch die Rechte haben
eine schlüssige Lösung zu bieten.
Der Kampf ums Land geht weiter.